big news big news nashville tennessee
march 11th ryman auditorium chrissy dean
sally babes the babe fest continues
tickets went on pre-sale one hour ago 10
a.m this morning promo code babe b-a-b-e
they go on sale to the general public
tomorrow so if you want to get the real
good seats you go on either
salvocanocomedy.com or
christiecomedy.com today with babe right
to second nashville
be a fake don't be a flake don't run
away from your feelings babe don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey do you have the time
to listen to hey babe
[Applause]
i'm wearing the pillow like this because
you know what i've been watching is a
lot of documentaries on queen elizabeth
yeah and this is how she used to dress
you look like a picture of the of the
madonna the mother mother
behind but this is also like if you look
at old movies of queen elizabeth they
would always have like almost like like
a protection as if somebody people would
walk past ancient queens just slam the
back of their heads into a wall like
they do like they do in the videos the
viral videos where they just punch
people on the streets yes which we got
yeah and she wears an oval pillow to
protect herself yes she does this is
actually if you tried this is actually a
good safety measure like if i was an
elderly person and you know a lot of
especially like in the cities a lot of
people if i was kane tanaka which by the
way
happy birthday kane tanaka 2019
119 folks and a lot of people are upset
that we didn't throw her a birthday
party still sexually active still
sexually active it was in the article
kane tanaka is still sexually active and
uh and um she said um
she said uh uh she got a birthday cake
from her family there and in japanese
letters it said kovit
she goes uh kane tanaka
by the way
i love that we are the ones that brought
kane tanaka
we gave life to kane tanaka on this
podcast and now cnn
is is reporting this nice try cnn uh
welcome to the party pal yeah welcome to
the babes have known this for a long
time so you know like anybody that
mentions kane tanaka to you tell them
shut up yeah back off ted turner yeah
ted you [ __ ]
um
he i think he owns my show oh yeah
sorry let's scale it back
yeah
yes teddy turner um
i um i i yeah so so uh yeah kane tanaka
turned 119 so you just want to of course
say a happy happy birthday
to her if it wasn't coveted times would
we have not thrown a tanaka birthday
bash oh my god we would have done it if
it wasn't coveted times i'm being dead
seriously if it wasn't cove at times
yeah i swear to god i would highly
consider if you had the time and we had
the time to go to japan and meet her for
her birthday like go to actual japan and
do an episode you find her and do a
birthday party from japan
you mean we'd go you mean we'd go there
without setting it up first
yeah go there find her yeah
can we just go there with a bundle each
yeah stick and be like we're in that
we're gonna hunt for kane yeah we're in
the hunt for kane tanaka uh she reminds
me of the old do you remember the golden
child with eddie murphy
i oh it was like a it was like a pretty
big comedy hit right after right after
the slew of like uh
right right after like uh yes yes yes
yes i've seen this before yes
cop yeah yeah there's there's that this
little kid and
there it is she me he reminds me of that
guy right this year that guy right there
do you know when he he has to go into
the there's a famous clip where he has
to go into like the caves or whatever
and he has to like spin the the column
yeah and ask for what he wants yeah and
he's looking for a special knife yeah
and he's like and he's like
can i and he spins he goes can i have
the knife and that little old guy comes
out he like picks his nose a lesion guy
and he's like you have to ask
differently and he's like
please you never see that one no i don't
that's what i remember it's a pretty
good one uh speak oh oh that part i know
for isn't that where that goes my
brother noomsie loves me yeah yeah yeah
we used to say that all the time when we
were kids you scored my brother noom she
loves me
wait so you remember it well i only
remember that part because me and my
friends you know when we were kids there
we go my brother knew him she loves me
i don't know um make that a sound bite
ready go my brother numpsy loves me
[Laughter]
clip
um so so um also too quick you know
indiana jones you know the movie you
know uh uh in the temple of doom short
round of course you know he grew up
booby trapped he's in some movie now
like he was in like a go short round
temple of doom actor whatever that guy's
actor he's from the goonies babe he's uh
yeah he's he's um
is he like a famous guy what's his name
in in in the goonies is his name i don't
know no he's he's yeah he's a big part
in the game i can't believe i'm
forgetting jonathan k juan i saw him in
a new netflix show or new or maybe it's
called the fall of saigon something but
i was like wow that's freaking short
round short round i love him love short
round um uh no time for love mr jones
right dr
dr jones uh
can you tell me who he plays in um in
goonies i mean
it's i feel like it's a name like
popular name like how we remember short
round
the goonies
oh
yeah
nice um
pip was pulling up too and we we need to
speak about this we've been how old is
he okay we've been sent this many many
times asian people don't have an age
okay they're ageless they're just
because he might he's 50 years old you
would never believe that that he's 50
years no he doesn't look 50 look at that
picture he doesn't look 50 at all no he
looks like he could say i'm 32 and i
would believe that i believe that yeah
he also also he also could like if you
told me that was a 30 30 year old woman
i believe that as well like they just
it's very difficult yeah
is it what do you think it is
i think that asian people and black
people like they they don't they age
very well well that and we've spoken
about this many times i think on this
podcast and and i think we have about
how korean people have a gene in them
where they don't produce body odor in
their armpits
when we bottle that and license it
together that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying like i've never
thought like why doesn't like secret
deodorant just use whatever the korean
armpit gene is and make that your
deodorant and then you have a stinkless
armpit where did you hear this
um just you know i i eat a lot of korean
barbecue i talked to the white staff
these are genetically mutated to have
less of a sweating problem than others
according to research yep 0.006 of the
korean population have the abcc 11 gene
a major culprit behind um what does it
say ric flair is blocking it
oh yeah so so they're they're they're
they're the um they're the most um
they smell the least they're the most
odorless uh race the korean so shout out
korea um
but uh and also sweat is my most second
most hated thing really what's number
one it's uh traffic sweat the common
cold strong wind bugs cats pointy
objects pointy objects and general filth
wow and and a common cold on vacation
will trump everything actually
interesting so so you'd rather have a
common cold on v
so you'd rather be stinky than have a
common cold on vacation yeah common cold
on vacation is one overall yeah traffic
sweat
regular common cold
strong winds bugs cats pointy objects
and filth now strong winds like when
you're in an airplane at your strong
winds in general no any any strong winds
especially if i'm about town
like if i'm walking and it's just
whipping winds you know there's nothing
you could do about it yeah it's gonna
it's gonna mess up your hair oh it's
gonna destroy your hair yeah and there's
nothing you could do about it you just
take it gotta take it especially uh you
know if you're wearing a t-shirt if it's
a warm day it's gonna it's gonna expose
the nipple oh it's gonna expose the
fatty nipple you gotta be jacked if you
wanna stand in a windstorm with a light
t-shirt 100 most polycotton blends today
full exposed nipple if you're out there
making a t-shirt why not make a t-shirt
that's a little thicker for people with
nipple puff yeah well any nipple really
i mean the way that these t-shirts are
falling on the skin now
expose the nipple even even a soft
nipple that's why what i do is a little
hack i try to get a t-shirt that has a
graphic on the front that goes nipple
wide can't see the nippies i like it um
um i actually wanted to ask because sal
just said his least favorite things in
life were what were your least favorite
things my least favorite things in life
i would say
um number one the heat i hate the heat
anywhere yeah so sweat i don't mind
sweating so much just the heat the heat
i don't like i don't like hot climates i
don't like the heat the beach is number
two i don't like the beach i know a lot
of people are like what you know i don't
like sand i don't like the beach i i
would what about the ocean though
to look at i don't want to go near i
don't care i'm a pool slash lake guy i
like that um see i don't like lakes
because
i just think there's a lot of creatures
in there that you don't want to do it's
not going to bode well at the end of the
day any body of water i don't love going
in if you force me i'd rather go on a
lake i'd want to go in a pool more than
anything yeah i just don't like the
beach i'm never a beach guy i don't i
just i it's not for me it's not for me
at all i don't like bringing the
blankets and the coolers to me it's so
much work i don't like either yeah i
don't like that um i also um i don't
like
i don't like cats
yeah you know i don't like cats i don't
want to kill cats at all but i i don't
really want or need ever in my life i
don't have a need for a cat a dog i
could be convinced of getting yeah yeah
but a cat is probably the last animal
i'd like in my mind they're unreasonable
i don't like them yeah i don't like
we're talking about getting a dog really
yeah what kind of dog it's up for grabs
it's up for debate you ready for this i
actually saw this in the daily news
yesterday they did
top uh dog bite attacks by breed in 2021
okay at least in new york number one pit
bull yeah number one pit bull but we
knew that number two you ready for what
number two it was so funny because
number one was a pit bull and it was
like growling number two oh no
it was just sitting that number three
chihuahua uh you know why they probably
are always on the defense yes because of
their size yeah they're little guys
well all
all dogs that don't shed
most dogs that don't shed are very ugly
i'm sorry everybody like you might
through my lens the dogs that don't
sheds are they did just like mop they
just like look like mops right they're
just mostly those moppy floppy like
smooshed face kind of like hair like
like long hairish kind of little
mops running around there's like 15 of
them i looked it up online and i'm like
no no ugly i'm going i'm going right
right i i originally like i i i was
looking then i looked at like a
dalmatian like like a brown spot of
dalmatian have you ever seen that yet no
i've had a dalmatian though you have i
had her name was cruella
she wouldn't know i swear to god she
well i had her when i she was 10 years
old she was 10 years old we had her and
uh she got down to the basement once and
ate all the clorox and bleach
puked was whole i think you told me this
the whole thing and then we and then and
then we gave her away
yeah yeah so but dummy but but
dalmatians are very very very hyper i
know that's actually what i read and
that that kaibashi for me i i saw my
first brown spot of dalmatian in
australia i've never seen one i was
hooked and then it said a couple things
one not good not great with kids right
two hyper is old [ __ ] three you need to
get them their exercise like an hour or
two a day and like i want to give the
dog what the dog needs but i do not have
the time for that do you have that time
so what so what what breed are you
thinking i also like beagles but i don't
want the howling i like a beagle uh i
looked at a
what about like a bulldog
right you like a bulldog i do but i feel
really bad because i don't think
bulldogs are natural i think we made
bulldogs and i think they i think they
have like hundreds of problems up at
birth and it's a it's a race against
their their genetic problems they've got
heart issues and drool issues and
they're they're fat and they've got eye
issues and respiratory issues what about
a sharp pain the ones you could just
squish its fees what's your sharpay look
like people pay it's just it's just
layers of fat coming over its face
drooping it's like literally i mean it
looks like it has waves on its body look
at this well that pimp just googled
sharpie dog so there it is oh those
things are huge
yeah it looks like a vagina no it does
look like a vagina it actually looks
like he bought a dog suit that was too
big for him yes yeah
like like jesus was making him when he
put on the wrong suit he's like god damn
it
i'm like babe
ah she has the head that's what bulldogs
look like what's the kind of dog that uh
that that is bandit
well my buddy ari has a dog named ben
that's a basenji and a rat terrier it's
the perfect size perfect temperament the
coolest dog i've ever seen this one
right
here that's only one that's a basenji
but
mixed with a rat terrier and you get you
get you get this other dog in here so i
don't even know if you could do that i
think it was just like a mutt that he
got are you allowed to do that
i don't know can you even can any dog
yeah i don't know if you can a great
dane have sex with a chihuahua it can
and then what
what happens
what the hell don't know first of all
the chihuahua will be demolished no yeah
i mean i think it's pot
how about a chihuahua f and a great team
just like up on a stepladder or
something it could i think that it could
but i think some of them don't donut
what do you got do you think it's creepy
to be someone that breeds animals yeah
my uncle my uncle breeds cats what yeah
he's gotta he breeds cats up in his
house and he's got like stinks cats dude
my uncle i have an uncle you ready for
what i'm about to tell you i have an
uncle
world renowned cat judge he goes all
over the world and judges cat
competitions
all in all
let's just do it how do you not bring it
up google russell webb russell webb
judge
s-s-e-l-l-w-e-b-b
cat judge dub cat judge this is my uncle
russell there it is thank you to judge
go let's let's let russell webb yeah
here we go this is my this is my
mother's
brother this is my uncle this is my full
uncle this is his job and it's live
shout out my uncle russell he's been to
every corner of the world judging cat
competitions
look at him he's got a great uh
yeah he's got a great professional
sports name
[Music]
i'm proud of him for this i'm proud that
this is my uncle how do i know you for a
decade and you don't bring up russell
webb i have no uncles mother's brother
is a world-renowned cat judge world
renowned gets flown first class all over
the world he's the one that breeds him
he breeds so a good day for him his best
day is full of cat sex sad cat sex
that's his best day he wakes up and then
and the cats are
that's what it is that's why he's alive
we can only go over his house like one
day a year because the rest of the days
just can't
all along yeah he can't do it
he i feel like struggling to take calls
he's like
keep it down sorry man
many cap breeders do not make a profit
and some do not manage to break even
after the amount of medical bills food
and other supplies so why are they doing
it i would love to get my uncle russell
on the podcast because i've never asked
him how did you wind up in that because
i'm talking about like there are only
five cat judges in the world and he's
one of them like he's like a master
sommelier no he's got he's gotten flown
out by like royalty to like judge cat
competitions i think he was in china
when everything was going down in the
beginning of of 2020 like and like got i
think he got i'm not could be i've just
misheard this but i'm almost positive
that china shut their borders and he was
judging a cat competition and only a
select few of non-chinese citizens could
get out and he got out like the chinese
government was like get out russell webb
he's too important to lose
yeah he has uh he has immunity
diplomatic community
is he dangling a fake mouse in front of
that cat on the right on the right
yeah he might i don't know but this is
his entire life and i'm proud to be his
nephew yeah i'm proud to be his nephew i
mean this is he's the most he is
literally i'm being dead serious as far
as you know status goes like you know i
do i do comedy and it's a beautiful
thing and and i'm proud of where i'm at
but i'm nowhere near the level in comedy
that he is in catch-up that's why he's
hall of fame he slays puss he's the dave
chappelle of catch-up yeah he's the top
guy in the catch-up my blood uncle
damn there it is yeah
and dog show judges get paid no i mean
my uncle russell's living large i mean
the dogs i mean you're a cat judge it's
a different it's a different echelon
dog dog show judges make from eighteen
thousand to fifty eight thousand uh
median salary of thirty three thousand
you can't live on that yeah you have to
do something else you know what my you
know what my uncle's other job is i
swear to god he's cat judged by he's
catch by day and then at night he runs a
[ __ ] cemetery no he runs a cemetery
that's where he gets the cats that's
where he gets the cat from he runs a
cemetery yeah he'll heal up all right
this podcast sponsored by better help
you know that we love it mental health
we take it very seriously sal's been
using it i've been using it we feel a
lot better broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas it's all over
zoom it's perfect it's professional
counseling what it is it's done online
it is secure it's nothing like a crisis
line you get a professional licensed
therapist um it's available worldwide
and you can start talking to someone
within two days 48 hours you log in you
can send a message to your counselor
anytime um
it is i mean they're blowing up they've
been with us for a long time and the
more i the more that i
that they i hear about them now yeah
everyone talks about them everybody i
mean the pope was talking about on the
other day was he really a sermon yeah
god bless sermon he said better help he
said he said jesus on the
his cross is better help i hope my
youngest daughter's first two words are
better help if you want to get 10 off
your first month all you got to do is go
to betterhelp that's help
betterhelp.com hey babe special offer
for hey babe listeners 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com slash hey babe
16. let me ask you a question if i said
to you do you think there's a way for
you to get 16 free meals and three free
gifts in your life from anybody i would
say [ __ ] you lied
[Laughter]
well i'm not because you can get it with
hellofresh hellofresh as we know is
america's number one meal kit and man oh
man it's fresh delivery right to your
door with unbelievable farm-to-table
ingredients and recipes that you can
cook in 30 minutes or if you're in a
rush 20 minutes if you don't know how to
cook it'll help to teach you if you
don't want to go to the grocery store
it'll save you time and money if you
want to cook something fun with your
kids that's another way to do it if
you're a single guy or gal yeah and and
you just don't have the time to look up
recipes man they package it all and they
serve it to you right in the chops try a
cheddar wonder burger they got dunkaroo
frostings they got all different types
of food they got hibachi sweet soy bevet
steak and shrimp who doesn't love that
they got a lot of great food and i've
learned how to cook with them and it's a
part of my life now and you can get an
amazing discount if you go to
hellofresh.com slash hey babe16 and use
the code hey babe16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts if you have a
16 year old daughter don't give her a
sweet 16. go to
hellofresh.com hey babe16 use the code
heybase16 and say here's your 16 free
meals come on and three gifts hello
fresh america's number one meal okay
always tell me like he has a he he got a
plot a family plot for us when i was
like six years old i know i will be
buried at holy root cemetery in long
island no yeah you've known for 31 years
what does he do there he's like a
bouncer no no he he's the guy no no he's
not a bouncer he's he you know if you go
through a loss you talk he runs the
cemetery so you talk to him about the
plot and but he he runs the show he's
been there for years what an eccentric
duck yeah you know yeah cat by day
cemetery by nine yeah i think i think
it's a beautiful thing i think that it's
a t i think it's a television show yeah
i do think it's a television show can we
do a podcast from the cemetery hundred
percent i'm not going that'd be cool
right if you're uncle russell i mean
this is fine right we're learning
amazing things amazing i mean i'm
shouting out
shout out
if you die if you die go to um if you
die go to holyrood cemetery get buried
there and then after your funeral go to
bocce it's right across the street great
italian food in in national account
that's how you do a funeral that's how
you do it now batting number one
russell webb yeah yeah number one shout
out russell webb i could picture that's
such a good name yeah
yeah he has he has like when you go up
to his uh house i haven't been there
quite some time but when i used to go up
he has like a full
like um it's like a sex den tent for his
cat breathing like it's a full the last
remember it looked like a spaceship on
his top level of his home like like
because it's a lot pressurized and every
there's a lot of things that go wrong
it's to get cats in the mood there's
like shag carpeting you don't know what
it is but he's like a scientist with it
like i i'm telling you he
like he is like if you are in the cat
world you're [ __ ] dead right now that
that's my uncle like you like the ones
like awards upon awards cat twitter is
going nuts didn't say anything to us i
remember not we didn't even know as a
family and then i think he was supposed
to come to thanksgiving or one holiday
and
he couldn't make it and you know my
mother was like russell where he was
like i'm at it i'm at the airport in you
know saigon and he was like she was like
why i was like i'm judging a cat
competition they were like excuse me wow
and then he was like yeah you know it's
something that i i'm pretty passionate
about he was i mean now he's just it's
blown up now you can't keep it secret
anymore wow so shout out russell webb
the cat judge what what skill set and
knowledge do you need to have to judge
the camera i think he always loved
animals he's always been a guy that love
i remember even when my mom with cruella
i remember he would try to you know 20
years ago you know give my mom tips so
he's always loved animals so i think he
just he just didn't give your mother the
tip don't give cruella the clothes yeah
the only thing yeah don't i would not
the last thing i do is feed her clorox i
wouldn't do your laundry inside your
dog's stomach
um but yeah so what did your mother
think of uh the cat uncle
what do you mean did they get along oh
yeah yeah no my mom is a family of four
sisters and and my and one brother my
uncle so so he was like the you know the
big brother of the family nobody rolls
their eyes at his cat life no no but he
doesn't talk about it much though like
like it's almost like when we're like
out of holly i'm like you know so what's
up in the cat world he'll just be like
that's all i do it's all people asking
about police i don't want to tell you
he's like yeah
yeah no i can't no i think like when he
gets i don't know this for sure but i'm
almost positive like china is the big
market for it like i think when he gets
off the plane there it's like police
detail like
like it's
like he's no joke in china like i think
it's like a big huge thing
he comes off the plane like frigging the
president like air force one yeah how
many times are they like in a situation
where like we need web we need weapons
yeah like there's been a tie
at the local municipality and in in
wherever and they have to fly into the
big guns i feel like he's like james
bond of the cat world no it's crazy yeah
and the way he does it's precise and
because there's all these things you got
to do like i've watched him judge a
couple of videos like there's things
that you wouldn't even look at like i
look at him like that's just a cat but
he's like you know and he'll do blah
blah blah this one gets a seven and then
he like passes it along and can you pull
up a video of it because it's just he
really gets in there i'd love to see it
yeah let's play some audio russell webb
catch us just go to the video um how
could you never mention the story
you never mentioned on the pod no i've
um we talked preview
gc now uh yeah try this just put the
volume on oh this is during the pandemic
oh he feels like fancier's association
that's what he's the president of wow
he's great i'd love to get him at a
dinner party let's get him on the pod
here come on i'd love to have mine but
on the taste buds episode cat versus dog
uh sal's real issue with cats is that
they're very sexual towards him yeah
interesting well they're very sensual
animals like they come up and purr and
rub on you when you don't ask for it
right they're very like uh they're very
not of this time interesting yeah no
that so so in other words you think cats
actually are gonna they should be me too
i i think that they i think someone
should check them yeah because for ages
now for far too long they just come up
and rub on you and they purr on you and
they wrap their tail around you and
stuff when you i i don't want to be any
it's too close for comfort yeah i don't
like it it did not
they don't they don't respect personal
space yeah yeah i i i i've never liked
cats and it's odd because it runs in my
family to love cats and i've never liked
it yeah dogs i'm a dog guy you know i i
am so i would i i would i guess that's
the only time i would agree with derosa
on that but i guess you know i had a
friend i have a i had someone who i used
to like you know me in my life whatever
and he knew someone who who bred
and trained rottweilers for competition
okay what do they do for competition i
like in like the westminster jump over
the same thing where they look the the
runner the owner runs with them on the
leash and they're just all the same and
the physique and the form and the the
listening and the dexterity i don't know
i don't know what it is but he did that
and then he also trained him like
as attack dogs right okay and then my
sister decides they they got they're
getting rid of this dog they can't keep
them anymore so my sister takes it on as
a pet it's a 120 pound rottweiler she
takes on as a pet i go to her house she
has it in the cage because if it's not
in the cage it will attack but by the
way when you come in the house and
they're in the cage they go wild because
they are stuck in the cage and they i
don't know it's something like
also when you leave the house if the dog
gets acclimated then you go to lead the
dog would attack so the dog hat would
attack for many different reasons okay
and
when i first went there the dog tried to
attack me like i mean you know when a
dog's barking and you're like if that
dog is free i'm gonna get mauled yes
like the the barking that's like like
deep like like like like yeah like i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna rip
you to pieces not like they're roll roll
like that like like they don't know what
the [ __ ] do this drool and everything i
hate you
hurting themselves trying to get out of
the cage right that's what it was like
and then
when she ever got it out of the cage and
i was there at any given moment it might
come over to try to nip me and then
anyone who left it would run and try to
attack you right it got a little less as
the dog got acclimated to like real
people than not just trained to like be
an attack dog but over the years that
dog has bit
easily like seven eight people
my family yeah it's been my
brother-in-law three times like a full
ride
tried to bite me in the face when i got
too close to it because i think it was a
little bit abused at one point i don't
know anyway it was then my dad takes the
dog
god bless the dog the dog recently
passed okay it was in the family like 10
years right but
even up to last god god bless r.i.p but
the family's a little safer now
even we're a little safer even even a
year ago after the dog is getting older
and was with us for like eight nine
years it was still a roll of the dice if
the dog would bite you
so you would be uncomfortable around it
a lot i no i wasn't uncomfortable unless
i knew what not to do you can't go like
right in his face or be a little too
rough right other than that the dog was
a sweetheart but there were things that
a flip switched when something happened
anyway you just get like a little
erratic
so like even my dad
like there were times where the dog
growled at him and i'm like this is wild
that you have a dog for 10 years that i
mean the dog loved my dad he wouldn't go
anywhere without him but last year the
dog bit two people wow like heart and a
rottweiler bite is a like not like maul
them and rip them just like a snap and
then like ah break skin even wow
did you now i think the question
everyone has did your dad give the dog
apple cider vinegar shots
you think it did i think the dog got all
the accoutrements and vitamins that my
nutrients that my father ingested your
dad's a good person yeah i'm always
curious when people have like jack dogs
how do you get your dog ripped i think
he's just constantly exercising it
constantly bringing it out to the park
or whatever i think really that's all it
is is just letting them run free
every single day from my dad's point of
view uh the dog had uh went used to la
fitness
the dog was on
testosterone and hgh um yeah and and
pimp was pulling up a story before um
about uh someone who we've mentioned on
the podcast before but the girl who
farts in the jar actually had to go to
the hospital and i was retired from it
yes because she had a heart attack
because i i don't know if there's a
constant pressure and squeezing i i read
what it was about what was what happened
she was deaf motto was her name by the
way she was she was pounding down uh
three protein bars a day protein shakes
so she can get the gas going and she
ingested i think way way too much
protein and she got it was actually gas
pain but actually if you've ever had it
that could be a shooting you could feel
like a heart attack guess yeah yeah yeah
so they told us she has to stop that
right she's okay she has to keep up with
the demand yes she's a fartrepreneur as
they say um
my beans and eggs is the big part of her
diet by the way if you're trying to
bottle up your farts i wanted her to
come over uh to the house and do if she
don't want to do the hay bay podcast to
come do the chrissy chaos podcast
because i wanted her to fart in my cold
oatmeal jars i thought that would be
nice yeah we should we should have her
on would you like to have her on i tried
she's retired i was talking to my lady
about it i explained the situation and
she couldn't even understand
the baseline premise of the farting in
the jar and people paying for it i know
a person i didn't know what to say i
know a person that told me they knew
what building she lived in because maybe
all right edit that part out um
here start from here i know someone that
knows where she lives okay but it's all
good they're like friends okay said the
apartment is
stunning she makes oh
the moment stinks
no he said
stunning apartment she must have made a
fortune and now it's kind of tough for
you know because everyone has different
streams of revenue like now because of
her health scare she can't make a living
now and she may have to forfeit that
apartment well she could still she could
still bottle up natural ones it's just
gonna be she's gonna be down to like
eight grand a week so what i would do if
i was her steph motto if you're
listening and i know that you are yeah
if you're listening what i would do then
is charge a premium instead of go
quality over quantity so change the
business plan to it's not how many times
i can fart it's the type of fart that i
can give in the jar is what costs so i'd
be willing to pay for a more premium
fart right as opposed to just one of
many right or if she's not blessing 50 a
week if she's only doing five then those
are more rare now
the price goes up rare air rare air rare
air that should be the business yeah we
should coin it wow you guys should
manage her yeah i would love to manage
her
your friend
[Laughter]
you just leave the biz
you stop managing her i'm managing my
client you get a business card
no um uh your friend who knows where she
lives whatever that's a male it's a male
okay but it's not they're friends no i
just love the fact because it i don't
think there's many other people besides
me that would go by the way i saw the
apartment
stunning stunning
stunning no he said it's fantastic also
you know who else is stunning tom brady
i just want to give him a quick shout
out god bless tom brady you won the
super bowl
i mean the ones he's the reigning super
bowl champ tampa bay bucks at home in
tampa be remiss if we didn't mention
patrick mahomes and the kansas city
chiefs great job out there guys better
luck next year which is this year could
happen could happen we'll see
everybody's in the hunt everybody's not
hey and your steelers got in oh how
nervous were you last night dude i i
actually had a uh migraine afterwards i
had a a splitting headache from
detention so if you guys don't know let
me just let me just set the stage three
things that had to happen okay so the
big thing was as long as the steelers
had to win which they did but that was
on the road
in baltimore right which is very
difficult to win there yeah team rival
and then
they would have gotten in as long as
not even what jacksonville who were two
and fourteen
had to beat the colts they had two who
were nine and six i think if the colts
won all bets were off still doesn't
matter what happened so the so the
jaguars win
they're the worst team in the league
they're getting the number one overall
pick they had to beat the colts
and and they did and they beat them and
they they beat them up yeah so that's
two phases then the third one was as
long as the chargers and raiders didn't
end in a tie which is very rare it
happens more nowadays but it's not very
well it happened one time this season of
all the hundreds of games dealers and
the detroit lions
one time so that all they have to do is
the charges the chargers are winning
by
what fifth i'm sorry the raiders are
winning by what it was a close it was
pretty close the whole game no but but
at the buzzer
the chargers tied it right tied the game
with two seconds left to bring it into
overtime if you watch football they
march down the field with like less than
two minutes left and they hit he
converted four fourth and tens four
you're watching every second in this
game every second he converts herbert
converts four fourth and tens and then
he gets
uh just a little sideline pass and and
it was under review because there was no
time left and they called it a catch and
then he took a shot at the end zone
right and he scores with no time left
and then they and prior to that he had
to get they needed two touchdowns and a
two-point conversion to tie and they got
it with zero seconds left with zero
seconds left and then they got it and
then so now they go into overtime
29.29 29 i think it was 29 29 yeah but
literally
at there was two seconds left in the
game before the raiders kicked a field
goal and won the game at the buzzer in
overtime if they would have missed that
field goal even though jaguars lost even
though steelers won that game would have
ended in a tie which is so improbable
and the steelers would have been out
they must to the last second you must
have been panicked i have a video of me
watching it i want to see it yeah
and also it's it's ben's it would have
been ben's last game ever and now he
gets to go to the playoffs who do they
play in the first round now the chiefs
the chiefs which is are they saturday or
sunday they are sunday at 8 15. so we're
going to we're going to watch it here
what do you want to do we're going to be
in cleveland on stage
all right
yeah what can you do
this by the way this friday and saturday
i'll be in austin texas you want to come
shows are sold out almost
oh my god
[Laughter]
i didn't know what to do with myself
dude he's literally sal is literally
laying on the table laying on his table
like it completely exhilarated and wow
yeah dude i was thinking about you i was
like oh my gosh
it was a 47-yard field goal by no means
not a child not a chip shot
and and what else was i going to say um
uh uh uh uh uh
oh [ __ ] also hd if the chargers
it it didn't really matter if you
couldn't he could have kneeled so this
is the other and then they both would
have gotten in this is the other crazy
thing the chargers and the raiders are
playing
whoever wins their game goes to the
playoffs the other one gets eliminated
they're in the same division they have
the same record so they're playing to
get in however
if they tied they both would go in and
the steelers would not go in so at the
time that they the game finished in
regular in regular uh time and in ot
that whole time they unless someone
scored they were both getting in so with
that two seconds left if carr decided to
just take a knee because by kicking
he still opens the raiders up to a small
chance of something happening like the
kick could get blocked and returned for
a you know returned for a touchdown
something could happen in that two
seconds and they wanted to win and they
did it but if he took the knee right
there which he could have done because
at that moment before they could be in
the playoffs and the raiders were
definitely in if he knelt they were
definitely in but if he kicks the field
goal they're both in so this is
crazy if either one of them lost if the
raiders somehow lost or or if the charge
lost they were out whoever wins gets in
but the tie they're both in and the r
and the wow that and the steelers were
out yeah and it was just wild because
like you said would you be mad at the
raiders if you were the chargers or no
because you got to play to win the games
you you got to play to win right yeah
you have to play i didn't have data do
anyone a favor also you're my division
rivals yeah yeah suck my ass yeah suck
his head no suck my ass but justin
herbert shout out good for you uh you
guys ever heard of this sport i just
found this looking around what's this
chess boxing have you ever heard of this
chess boxing no no but this seems
interesting
yeah is this like wu-tang
no this is like a real thing i just
found there's an actual organization of
chess boxing so so there we wait
a
minute
it's two boxers in the ring they play
chess and then box apparently oh my god
okay so it's a hybrid sport that
combines two traditional disciplines
chess and boxing two combatants play
alternating rounds of speech yes and
boxing so it's mind and body kind of
till one wins by checkmate or knockout
it is also possible to win by time
penalty as in normal chess and by boxing
decision if there is a draw on the chess
board which is so this is so amazing
because you could have the advantage in
chess but then get this legit brain and
then still stay alive and have to now
play chess with one eye play chess with
a concussion this is a full-on
like
this thing is regulated it's the world
chess
boxing championship was produced by
london chess boxing
how have we never heard of this okay
here are the rules a match consists of
11 alternating rounds of chess and
boxing starting in alternating rounds
yes
oh my god oh my god that sounds like the
most amazing thing i've ever seen on one
chest round two boxing and then you come
back at the chessboard that's what it is
you get just
jabbed in the face that's what i was
saying you're bleeding and you're like
rook to queen you have to do it we
should do this for spelling bees yes oh
my god
each round lasts three minutes followed
by a one minute break the chess rounds
are played under time control with a
total of nine minutes allotted to each
player no increment added to either
player's clock after a move is made this
is i cannot believe that this has not
taken on
what bigger what happens if you get
knocked out
before the chess game then you lose i
think if if you get knocked out
i think if you get knocked out
at all in boxing or chess it's over oh
right i love that there's weight glasses
no this is this is um this is
unbelievable light weights 154
middleweight 1676 198 light heavyweight
heavyweight 198 and over okay so i
thought you played the chess game and
then you boxed that's amazing because so
then if you checkmate someone they can't
knock you out after that oh yeah
let's go back to the video pimp they're
playing chess with their boxing hands
look at that yeah the hands are look and
then let's see let's just give me a
second can we see it like i want to see
them go from chest to box yeah they have
headphones yeah and then back to chess
okay here they're getting up now oh
lights go
his down fighting pawn as the gloves go
on
and the ring is clear for man to man
battle
this is
where sports is heading and where it
should be heading
just as they did at the chessboard
the two men are being careful feeling
each other out
i can't believe this is real who crosses
with his right hand and catches france
with a glancing blow to the chin oh my
god they're decent boxers too i like
that he's he's he's calling the fight
with they're just their first names
nikolai hits frank it sounds so weird
do you think they have different um like
boxing instructor versus chess
instructor you have to i think you have
to have one two coaches
you gotta and he catches frank
with a left hook and a straight
frank into the corner but frank shows it
i thought he just sit back down
and they put on headphones breathing
they're sawing breathing sweating for
concentration they put on
noise-canceling headphones
he's got a fat lip he's breathing heavy
no because the mental fortitude that you
need to sit back down and concentrate on
chest and to get knocked around in the
head whoever thought of this is genius
because
almost actually every person i know
who's a boxer loves chess like my friend
sergio chacon who works with me on the
road he's loves boxing he's a boxing
instructor and he plays chess daily with
his kid
maybe they go hand in hand like the
mystery of chess boxing isn't that
what
hold on a second what is this it
isn't that what's on the back of your
phone by the way oh it's um what is that
it's a new battery that you just came
out with which by the way the mystery of
chess boxing
like famous wu-tang song i
i just thought they made up that term
chess boxing started
roughly like
2003
well the game of chess is like a sword
fight you know the opening you must
think first before you move but i wonder
if they used to play chess and then have
a sword fight and then play chess oh so
this is a thing that's been around you
know the song
i mean it's one of the most
abe you know i use expressvpn prior to
them
going with the podcast i bought i buy an
annual membership on my own right i use
it on my phone and my computer and let's
let's let's let's say what they want us
to say here does what about the idea
that a single company controls ninety
percent of internet services
and gets to track everything you do on
your smartphone thank you no thank you
big tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal disgusting it's
time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity and these
tech juggernauts yes and that's why we
use expressvpn it's like a condom for
your internet searches it makes it safe
think about how much of your life is on
the internet expressvpn also encrypts
100 internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers those little
pieces of [ __ ] on your network and
expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection that's the main
thing it doesn't slow anything down it
was rated the number one vpn service by
mashable and tech raider and what i like
most about expressvpn is how easy it is
to use and right now if you go to
expressvpn.com
hey vape that's e x p r e s s v p n dot
com slash hey babe you will get three
extra free months on your thro on your
subscription so you go to go to
expressvpn.com hey vape right now you
get three extra free months so stop
handing over your personal data the big
tech monopoly that mind your activity
and sells your information protect
yourself with the vpn that we trust to
keep safe online
what do you want to do tonight babe you
want you want to do a home-cooked
favorite or what do you want to do
normally i might want to use the cookie
service that we just spoke about but
when i don't when i don't use it do you
know who i call
doordash i go on my app i go on doordash
and i get food delivered even from
places that don't deliver themselves
which is opened up a whole new world
this is just another reason for me why
another reason to love double d's
doordash get drinks snacks and other
household items in under an hour they
got 300
000 parts it's not just restaurants no
it's not just restaurants babes you can
get groceries you get anything you want
but if you want restaurants popeyes
chipotle cheesecake factory whatever you
want but you could also go to the
neighborhood go to's which is what i
like to help with the small mom and pops
and for a limited time our listeners are
going to get 25 off and zero delivery
fees on their first quarter of 15 or
more when you download the doordash app
and enter the code hey babe that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code hey babe don't
forget that's code hey babe for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
to change terms apply i thought they
made the chest boxing can you do a a
chest boxing origin or when wednesday
invented
oh look 1970 what does it say right
there i can't read it hold on chess
boxing instead
they say wu tang early years in homage
to the film of the same name
oh yeah they always take all their stuff
from the the old uh
the old 1993
boxing into popular consciousness for
the first time in 93. the first chess
boxing competition took place in berlin
in 2003. wow if you're out there email
uh the podcast ebaypodcast gmail.com or
just tweet at us at heybaypod or
instagram us at heybaypod and tell us do
you know chess boxing are you involved
in it do you want to get involved do you
want to see me and chess have a me and
sal have a chess boxing match
oh so see chess boxing was just a form
of
a variant of chess in a kung fu film so
it wasn't what it is now when they said
it but then in 2003 somebody was like
let's just punch each other and then
play this is what if you want to impress
me this is what i want to see jake paul
do chess boxing i'd like to see him
chess box somebody yeah i've never heard
of any of these weird sports extreme
ironing is another one
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] read it it's an extreme
ironing also called e.i is an extreme
sport in which people take ironing
boards to remote locations and iron
items of clothing extreme ironing is the
latest danger sport that combines the
thrills of an extreme outdoor activity
with the satisfaction of a well-pressed
shirt
it says according to the extreme ironing
bureau there's a photo of a guy at the
peak of a rock mountain
he's alone at the summit it's so small
and he just opened up his ironing board
he's ironing some locations uh where
such performances have taken place
include a mountainside of difficult
climb a forest in a canoe while skiing
or snowboarding on top of a bronze
statue in the middle of the street
underwater
in the middle of the m1 motorway race
while parachuting and under the ice
sheet of a frozen lake the performances
have been conducted solo or by groups
extreme ironing was invented by phil
shaw in 1998
near settle in england inspired by his
eccentric brother-in-law who ironed his
clothes even when camping in a tent
[Laughter]
tony until 1990 tony often carried
ironing boards plus iron in his car boot
or on the lookout for opportunities to
cause bystanders to glance twice
thinking did i really just see that
oh we should extreme iron oh dude hey
hey hashtag hey babe extreme ironing
look at this guy look look at him
ironing underwater oh my god how stupid
is this the shirt soaked
and this is a legitimate thing let's do
it baby you guys could be the jordan
they're they need a jordan honestly
because that's the thing like should we
bring this to the public if it's not
because that's not in the public public
no extreme or here's the three literally
this is a this is a beautiful hey babe
episode because it's it should be called
maybe bombshells or what you didn't know
because we've brought now to the to the
masses yeah extreme ironing chest boxing
chess boxing and my uncle ross russell
webb and russell webb the cat judge i
mean
literally
it's a beautiful thing now what is this
now cheese rolling this is called cheese
rolling okay so what's cheese rolling i
want this girl
this is crazy this girl her name is
jennifer sorrio shout out jennifer's
trying to know what your married name is
i went to kindergarten through eighth
grade with her get the hell out she's
not an actress at all she's just in a
[ __ ] grubhub commercial i swear to
christ on everything i love she's a full
grump up commercial her and her family
on everything i love yeah her whole
family's in it too yeah like her husband
and children wow that's a full grub hub
commercial that i see all the time it's
like she has bigger credits than me
[Laughter]
i went kindergarten through eighth or
she was like that she was like
kindergarten like my grade school crush
wow
cheese rolling is really stupid what is
cheese rolling
they race down a 200 yard long hill they
race after a round of double gloucester
cheese that is said rolling down first
i love it
it's a world famous event
is this it yeah let's see oh my god
it's like a cheese wheel oh they got it
they're holding a cheese wheel and then
they roll down this hill
let's see
the cheese we don't know they're rolling
the cheese down there the cheese is like
oh my god oh my god and then just like
50 dudes just run after and they're just
they're just eating [ __ ] dude this is
has to cause
wild
there's like a technique to it this has
to cause insane injuries i would love to
hear about the injuries at the cheese
rolling competition that is a fun hill
to watch these guys they they're
literally probably breaking bones
look at this
oh my god
they basically have to throw their body
and let and let the inertia take over to
get down faster than anybody else
oh my god eat [ __ ] because if you trip
once you're done and then they're taking
people out look at this
i somehow like this better than sanikon
no this is great
cheese rolling i would love to see this
in person the thing is the thing is what
what what you realize and again it's a
it's a double-edged sword is this had to
come about because whatever part of
england they're in there must be
absolutely nothing to do
it's the same thing that we said god and
listen we love you it's why they built
the arch in st louis it was such a
boring and [ __ ] city that they said you
know what we need let's just build a
freaking arch yeah just to get people to
come looking at it and you know what you
did a great job did we did it got us we
got us yeah it's in like the rolling
hills of england yeah they probably do
nothing but you know super goats and
stuff and if you do it's your choice but
yeah we should shout out everyone that
came to the shows yes please thank you
everyone who came to babefest 2021 um we
have one date that we're adding babe
fest 2022 it's not on sale yet but just
just i would just say on march 11th just
be in nashville because me and sal are
doing the ryman auditorium
and it's not on sale yet but it's coming
so make your plans come to nashville
absolutely we also have a documentary of
the tour coming today yes we do homeless
pit made an entire hour-long documentary
of babe fest and joe derosa appears in
it too yes yes
everyone the shows were great thank you
guys for coming out the crowds were
great we had a blast uh is this coming
out thursday pimpy oh tomorrow i'm in
des moines saturday i'm in indianapolis
and sunday i'm in cleveland that's all
this weekend babes there's still some
tickets stuff indian cleveland come on
out des moines is sold out and i am in
austin texas folks friday and saturday i
think there's only a few tickets left
for the friday late show but come on out
see what you can do chrisdcomedy.com and
then my christy theaters tour starts
january 21st i'm co-headlining in
orlando with andrew dice clay and
january 22nd in tampa at the tampa
theater christy comedy.com me and
homeless pimpy will be there nice what
was your favorite part of the tour do
you guys have a favorite memory or
moment i liked uh shopping uh at that
place we went to in columbus thunder
[ __ ] um yeah that was great shopping in
columbus was good the food we ate
we went to uh we went to a dive bar that
that stayed open just for us cincinnati
cincinnati shout out to stanley's pub
shout out i loved when uh right when
chris was going on stage and i think
columbus sal came over to him told him
how many calories were in his meal he
just lobster gnocchi
yeah well i think we're in
texas somewhere with a cream sauce it
was the first night i think it was 2500
calories oh no i ate it in the majestic
theater in the green room san antonio
and chris was so hurt by the calorie
count that he forgot the mic and went on
stage
dude it was so that it was so much fun
just traveling we went we because we had
said we had said the day before on
christmas eve on christmas day we were
like hey
omicron whatever is is spiking
everybody's flights are getting canceled
it's all over the news we had to take
five flights in five days
we had to make sure nobody got covered
and we were like there's there's no
chance we're going to make all five or
six shows and we made all six shows yeah
it was unbelievable we made every flight
except the only ones you guys got
screwed at the end yeah yeah you didn't
they almost lost your luggage united is
the worst airline that has ever walked
the face of the earth if you thought it
was something like spirit start
replacing the punch lines to say spirit
with united united
they think and what we've discovered and
i i don't know why they get a bad rap
one of the best flying experience we've
ever had south west west southwest is
there's no frills you just sit the wi-fi
was perfect you watch the stuff on your
phone you get good snacks there was not
an issue at all with southwester shout
out southwest my last seven flights on
united
were three full-on cancellations and the
other four were all delayed between one
and three times the last flight i
finally took home from that trip my
flight was delayed two and a half hours
from uh cincinnati home then i got home
one hour on the runway and then we
needed to get towed into a gate and then
we waited 90 minutes for luggage pimp
was with me
and then after 90 minutes at the
complaining from 60 minutes 90 minutes
they said they don't know what happened
they told us our luggage never got on
the flight here we go crazy it's on the
next flight and that flight's too late
do you want us to mail you your luggage
he had all the expensive equipment in
there like we'll just wait it out we
wait another hour
so that's united what'd you eat when you
got home
i had to eat something big big right you
got to go big for that yeah i think on
the way home
on the way home yeah we ordered on the
right you go italian you go greasy i
know what i did what'd you do
we ordered from
dinino's yummy yummy in my tummy we got
a dino's pizza and i got a uh raviolis
which they use pistoza raviolis which if
you know what i know pistols is uh you
know old-school ravioli the best
let's get a treat to myself let's get an
italian lunch now i have no qualms with
that at all i want to do that i'm
actually
wishing for a joe de rosa sandwich i
haven't had one in a long time we me and
homeless pimpy went to joe derosa's last
week we got drunk we filmed it we got
drunk the sandwich the the beefy was
it's the best sandwich i've ever had if
you are in the new york city area
visiting you live there go down to joey
rose's salmon shop as much as i i want
to smash his head through a wall
the sandwiches are some of the best i'm
not lying the best cold cut sandwiches
i've ever had in my life
are that beefy might be the best cold
cut sandwich i've ever had period 174
remington once i before the bread is
fantastic so good
it's just it's just great
the only problem with the whole thing is
that joe derosa's face is on the menu
that's the only issue it was so great
chris was drunk causing a scene out
front a woman was walking by with her
dog and he stopped her and said you see
this face and he points to joe's face on
the front he goes does this make you
want to stop and eat food from here and
she goes no actually it's repulsive
she said i won't buy food from here now
amazing joey rose just go tweet at him
tell him he's a piece of [ __ ] hey babe
thank you bubs um this is good yeah you
know the whole episode because i just
want to commit to the bit i am it's been
slowly because it's so tight on my neck
i've been slowly losing consciousness i
can't believe that's still there slowly
losing consciousness i actually can't
breathe
this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey